resent the nominees in the category best
costume design two of the most beloved
actors to ever grace the screen the
delightful scarecrow in the sentimental
Tin Man ray Bolger and Jack Haley
well thank you very very much mr. hailey
it's some time since we went down that
yellow brick road together it's so 40
years to be precise uh do you think we
could do it again oh sure we might do
ease on down but we do we make it you
will huh well
amen to that now I think we ought to get
on with the nominees for outstanding
costume design why not yes well oh I see
it's my turn yeah yeah thank you very
much
we'll both read the nominee we need the
Cowardly Lion us what we need it we'll
both read the nominees and then I'll
open the envelope and announce the
winner well how come you get to announce
the winner if your son was producing
this show you would announce the winner
and I thought you had a heart I thought
you had a brain
nominees for outstanding costume
designer Renee Connelly for Cara bands
Patricia Norris for Days of Heaven
Anthony Powell for the death on the Nile
falls a stern image with the swarm Tony
Walton for the Wiz and the winner is
Anthony Paul for death on the Nile
I'm overwhelmed by the honour thank you
very much indeed I'd like to share this
enormous honor with the terrific people
who without whom no costume designer can
work people who made the costumes who
worked all night most of the time making
costumes overnight German are on sale at
London
Barbara matira of New York and Philip
link of London thank you very much
indeed thank